Fred oh my goodness he just deserves
such
a flower
[Music]
introduction in Northern California lies
a place So Divine where Rolling Hills
meet redwoods and the sun doth shine
where animals who are rescued now roam
free Rancho compassion is the name of
this
Sanctuary so Jasper that's angel she's
brown and then Lou is the big black
[Music]
cow and at the sanctuary lives a
resident so Charming he's warm
gregarious and oh so
disarming his plumage Divine his waddle
bright red I'm pleased to introduce you
to a turkey named
Fred
the Helix school's coming today I'm
waiting for them to they'll be here any
minute no there's Fred is inside do you
remember Fred yeah Freddy Freddy the
turkey let's walk towards the barn if
that's okay
yeah you say hi to Fred hi Fred
oh Fred who's that do you notice the
color of Fred's head how it's changed a
little bit was it really red when he
first got here yeah why so he's a little
more relaxed it's like a mood ring yeah
okay yeah yeah oh so it Chang his colors
yeah with his mood also or like
temperature what his body is at yeah
dancing with friend yet today though he
we had one tap dance maybe that will
help yeah show
so our turkey here is Fred aair and he
got his name because he does a little
tap dance for people like you know the
famous Fred to
stare he's doing his tap dance for you
Jasper yes he's so
excited it's kind of made my day you
know
Fred aair is Rancho kassian's Ambassador
Fred
aair is the greeting committee he is the
first to come out and greet everybody
and he shows all of his beautiful
plumage he'll walk right up to you and
parade around you give you all kinds of
angles so you can see just how glorious
and fabulous he is and what he's
communicating is welcome this this is my
home my territory he's the head hon show
he's the boss around here and we let him
claim that
[Music]
title we love to just like yell his name
Fred and then he sends out a gobble in
return but Fred a stair wasn't always
destined to thrive for if he hadn't been
rescued he wouldn't be alive Fred St and
Ginger Rogers his former mate were
rescued from some sort of Heritage
turkey operation getting ready to to
sell Fred and ginger and all these other
turkeys for for Thanksgiving she's over
there carries that way but now at the
sanctuary Fred's safe as can be okay
living a life where he's loved and free
so upon wake up when you open up the
doors he'll jump down from where he's
perching and it's this huge loud
sound it's almost like a plane taking
off but can't quite take off and then he
starts his day oh hi Mr
Fred good morning
Fred just knows how to handle himself
with the
ladies and it doesn't even matter what
species you are you don't even have to
be a turkey you can be a human being
when you see Fred strutting his stuff
you are seeing a fullon courting ritual
so you're going to see him fill up his
chest with air and he's going to expel
all of that air at once while taking
sort of a big stride
forward at the same time he's dragging
his tail feathers on the ground
producing another sound
effect he's also going to be vibrating
his
feathers
all of this behavior is called drumming
and then he might do a top dance for
you here some
stamping and it's not just sounds that
Fred creates he also changes colors for
potential mates you're going to see Reds
you're going to see Blues you're going
to see purples you're going to see that
his snood which is this dangly thing in
front of his beak is elongated normally
it's retracted into a little cone right
on top of his beak all of these features
that he's going to use to communicate
this is his territory and he is a
suitable
mate how you doing mister oh you going
to get me hey that's not very
nice you going to eat his tail feathers
Fred now that's not very nice
either everyone's getting worked up cuz
it's molting
season in the sanctuary Fred the jester
of the crew pecks at people's faces
causing quite a halloo he chases those
who guard themselves with a rake but
Smokey his dear friend also knows how to
prank at Meal Time Fred and Smokey share
their Delight from a bowl or from a hand
they love to take a
bite and in the summer heat some animals
opt for a tan while Fred seeks the shade
or cools off by the
fan one horse and a cow to the Apple
yeah if you bring some apples we could
feed them to the cow yeah love it I love
that idea a goat too absolutely yes
let's do that okay have a good rest of
your day everybody yes thank you we have
started youth program where monthly
students come out for a field trip and
last year we had a few visits from a
school called The Hunt School in San
anelo and at the end of the school year
last year the teachers had the students
right favorite moments of the year that
they had and a handful of the kids drew
Fred and said that that was their
favorite part of the school year which
was hanging out at Rancho kashion with
Fred a stair my favorite memory from the
school year is going to the Animal
Sanctuary I like s Fred the ch I got to
have him sit in my lap there was lots of
other animals too best field trip
ever you know we often assume that
animals are different from human beings
they don't have the same needs but in
terms of the need to communicate to
relate to be with others all species
have the same needs even
turkeys I wish more people understood
how family oriented they
are they're really sensitive
creatures when we lump them all into
some sort of Monolithic group and deem
them as unintelligent or unfeeling or
unempathetic then we're really missing
out on the ability to have a very
enriching inter species
relationship it's really hard to
imagine seeing someone sit down to a
Thanksgiving dinner and carve a turkey
knowing how deep their feelings are how
how much they're they're like us and or
your dog or cat oh Mr Handsome oh yes
the love that they bestow upon us it's
not something we think about we have to
deny that cognition about the capacity
for animal to feel if we're going to
take a bite of that
[Music]
turkey